now the toggles beautiful part  two-thirds are among the fifth section  of our laid-back southern city we  reevaluate painful in this life looking  for an experience to provide leadership  delivery of publish this book led to the  rotarians  taxes is painful 30 days will be the day  uses skills and experience to sort of  have sympathy for the public of high  esteem and our high technology and best  of all place here in the beautiful  Queens Park you couldn't ask for a  better location for your self the sounds  like you and you like to play a key  leadership role in the future of  undercurrents back services apply online  now at www.sec.gov 80 applications close  so so come join us at take lightly see  [Music]